- I'm looking forward
to getting a makeover
(laughs)
I'm so serious.
I will literally wear,
no I was about to say
anything on that rack but then--
(offscreen laughs)
then I looked.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] After the
selection of our prom court
we flew them all out to Los Angeles.
(upbeat music)
The first thing we do is give them
a tour of Buzzfeed
Motion Pictures Studios.
- Everybody right now,
you all are so fabulous.
(upbeat music)
- Did we all get the memo to
wear black and blue today?
(laughs)
Black and blue sounds a little
sad and melancholy, right?
We're gonna take you from
black and blue to rainbow.
So to help you on your
wardrobe styling journey
I'm gonna introduce a
friend of mine, Roman Sipe
who is a fashion designer and stylist.
Are y'all ready to try on
some fabulous prom wardrobe?
- Yes!
- Well you know what this means.
- Montage.
- No, no, no, no, no.
Once more, with feeling.
- Queer montage!
- Yes!
(upbeat music)
- I wanna feel like a hardcore lesbian.
Not like hardcore, but I
wanna be like this is me.
(cheers)
I want them to look at me
and say she's a homosexual.
- [Narrator] Expression in the
queer community through one's
wardrobe and one's styling is
a huge part of our identity.
(cheers)
- I'd probably go with the
jumpsuit because I feel like
the cape just makes it a
little bit more fierce.
- I am ready for the suit statement.
Floral jacket and then I wanted
some nice brown loafer shoes.
(cheers)
- Elegant, modern, and dramatic.
That is my style.
The dress with like weird cut-out pieces
maybe some geometric shapes.
Something totally weird
and unique and cool.
(cheers)
I just want to be snatched.
- Otter and Rowan, we have
another special trip for you.
We will bring you to our good friends
over at Sharpe Suiting to
get something custom-fitted.
- [ Narrator] There a lot
of people out there who are
struggling with the fact that
the clothes they've been given
since they were born might
not represent who they are.
- [Otter] Leon fitted Rowan and I.
He was amazing.
I didn't know that he was trans.
I thought he was just like oh yeah
a gay cis dude like it's cool.
Then he started talking
about binders and T
and I was like oh shit this is great!
(cheers)
- [Offscreen Person] Oh my
gosh, you are so handsome.
- I like the funky collar.
Finding, like, something that
actually fits me and my body
type is very hard because they
don't exactly make suits that
are tailored towards more
feminine looking people.
- I felt so proud.
I've never got fitted by a
trans person for anything.
Now I know why this suit fits me so well!
- Welcome, prom court,
to RA_ Bar Beauty here in
West Hollywood, the gay
capital of southern California.
We've assembled essentially
a superhero beauty team
and leader of it right
now is my very good friend
David Dang, who is a
celebrity hairstylist.
- Thank you so much you
guys for being here.
We were touched by your
stories and not only that
but we were touched because we support
the community in every type of way.
- Y'all know what this means.
- Montage!
- No, no, no, no, no. Say it right.
- Queer montage!
- It gets dumber every time.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
- Are you nervous?
- Excited.
- Good.
- Well, I love that. You're fabulous.
- I would love to deepen
your tone just a bit.
- Nothing too over the top
and just like, off the sides.
- [David] Are you ready?
- I'm so ready!
- Highlighter for the gods.
- Really dramatic eyeshadow
because I can't do that but like
if someone else can do that, sign me up!
(upbeat music)
- Do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do
It's like the ice cream truck of hair.
- Seriously.
- Plentiful.
- These are curled and ready to go.
- We wanted to keep this
a little bit of a surprise
but for some of the prom court supporters
like the parents and the friends
we will have some makeup
and hair for y'all as well.
The team is hear to support y'all.
(cheers)
(upbeat music)
- Wow!
That girl going to prom.
- Yes!
(laughs)
- I like it though, it's good.
It's really good.
- I look so good.
- Boo, you got style.
- Alright so I hope you enjoyed
a little bit of that pampering.
Does everyone feel good?
- Yeah.
- Y'all lookin' good.
I need you to go because we're
gonna meet later at the house
so you can see all of your children
and your friends' final looks.
So what are you doing?
Why are you still standing here?
Get out of here, get out of here!
Bye, Eugene!
Bye, Afsoun!
- Damn.
Zam.
- What do you think?
- It looks amazing.
I've never had my hair this tall before.
(laughs)
Wow.
- Yeah!
- It looks really good.
- White girl can cut!
(laughs)
Yeah how does it feel
to know how hot you are?
- You already knew that.
- Maybe.
(laughs)
- [Offscreen Person] 3, 2, 1
- Your hair looks so cool!
- Aww!
- What do you think?
- I think it looks good with the hair.
It's better than I
thought it was gonna look.
- [Stylist] Do you like it?
- Yes, I do like it a lot.
Thank you!
- [Offscreen Person] So handsome!
- Check it out!
- [Offscreen Person] Look at it go!
- Oh my goodness.
- [Stylist] It's so fun!
- What's happening to me?
I'm going to LA and I'm
getting everything changed.
I'm gonna go back and everybody's
gonna be like what happened?
I love it, thank you so much.
- Oh my god, have an amazing time tonight.
- [Offscreen Person] 3, 2, 1
- Oh!
Bitch, bitch.
David got me snatched.
David got me snatched!
Thank you so much!
- [David] No, thank you!
- Thank you so much, oh my (bleep) God!
For real, and like I've
never ever said about myself
but I can honestly say for
the first time in my life
like I actually feel beautiful.
Alright let's not get emotional everybody.
I need to drop it low in two seconds!
- So everybody's here.
You all look gorgeous.
- Thank you.
- Lee, are you excited to see Otter?
How are you feeling?
- I'm excited for them.
I'm like, what do they look like?
They better like kill it!
They better walk in here
like a runway model.
- Otter, Otter, Otter!
(cheers)
- [Offscreen Person] What?
- [Offscreen Person] Give us a twirl!
- Oh my god.
- I've never seen you this dapper.
- [Otter] I know.
I don't think I've ever felt
this masculine in my entire life.
- Have you seen him in a suit?
- No.
- Are you excited?
- Yes, I'm very excited.
This is really important to Christopher
and I'm just happy to be a part of it.
So I'm really excited to see him.
- Chris, Chris, Chris!
(cheers)
- Where's Chris?
I only see prints.
(laughs)
- Slayer!
[Offscreen Person] Christopher!
- I feel like we're matching, kind of.
- You are.
You coordinated that? You did that?
- [Offscreen Person] You look so good.
I mean you came in and you already slayed
so it's nice to just like
elevate you to the heavens.
- Your tiny baby caterpillar is now
a beautiful butterfly on her way to prom.
How pumped are you?
- Real excited.
Sage has worn all
different kinds of outfits.
She's had all different haircolors.
So normal to me but excited
to see her for this.
Excited for her.
- [Whispered Voice] Let's do it!
(cheers)
- [ Offscreen Person]
Let's see, turn it around!
Yes!
- Oh my god.
- Sad and excited.
- Why are you sad?
- Because this is my
little girl gettin' big.
- You're so cute!
- Sage, are you ready to see Caitlyn?
- Of course I'm ready to see Caitlyn.
- How excited are you?
- I'm really excited.
- Don, we ready?
- I'm ready.
(cheers)
- Oh my god!
- She looks really good.
- This is what you wanted.
- [Offscreen Person] Okay, power couple!
Matching accessories, oh I love that!
- I'm excited.
- [Offscreen Person] You
guys are runway ready.
- Rowan has no emotions and I'd like
to see like real person under my kid.
- Rowan, Rowan, Rowan!
(cheers)
- How are you feeling?
- I'm mixed emotions.
I'm nervous, I'm excited.
(cheers)
- You were the only one in a
suit not sure if people were
cool and now there's like,
you're not the odd one anymore.
- True.
- Everyone's equally--
- Equally odd?
- Equally odd!
- Equally queer.
- Equally queer!
- It's not like oh I'm just
going to prom to go to prom.
It's I'm going to prom to go to prom!
To be actually me at prom and not to be
something that my school wants me to be.
- Are you guys ready for the grand finale?
- Yes!
- How are you feeling, Af?
- I'm so excited that I might
actually (bleep) myself.
(laughs)
- Quinn, Quinn, Quinn, Quinn!
- Holy (bleep)!
(laughs)
- [Offscreen Person] Oh my god!
- I feel beautiful and honestly I can say
that's the first time I've
ever genuinely felt that.
Like I know that I may come
off as cocky or confident
but that all comes from
a place of faking it.
I really feel like having
gone through this experience
definitely boosted my confidence
and made me feel more like me.
- You look so beautiful.
You just look amazing.
- As much as it's your
dream, it's my dream too.
I've watched you through this whole thing
and (bleep) hell, you look good!
- [Afsoun] I think there was like
a disconnection between
appearance and personality.
Just seeing her being completely herself
and feeling beautiful is really incredible
because I know she does not
have a lot of self-confidence
often but I could tell you felt beautiful.
- I feel like I'm ready
to have a really fun night
a night I'll never forget.
Let's go to prom!
(cheers)
(upbeat music)
- [Sage] I'm excited to
wear exactly what I want
feel really confident and to
be feeling really confident
next to Caitlyn and knowing
that she's feeling good
and that we can, like, do anything.
- [Quinn] This Quinn that
you're going to see at the prom
is definitely the Quinn
that I want to express.
Fierce, fabulous, a queen, a badass bitch
and she does not take no for an answer.
- [Rowan] I'm with people
that I've barely met
yet I felt so comfortable with them.
So it was nice to share
the experience with them
and be able to be a part of it.
- Queer proud!
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Now that our
prom court has revealed
their gorgeous, stunning,
and sickening prom looks
they're gonna jump into a limo
and head over to Buzzfeed's queer prom.
- [Offscreen Person] How's
it feel being in a limo?
- Whoo!
- Feels pretty great!
- Oh my God, look there's rainbows!
(upbeat music)